was ist die beste seite am kapitalismus
meine damen und herren ganz einfach dass
er überwunden werden kann
das zumindest behauptet sahra
wagenknecht die seit ihren
teenagerjahren marx und hegel liest und
ihre begeisterung für den sozialismus
nicht als jugendsünde abtut sondern als
real politische vision weiter verfolgt
heute unter anderem in ihrer rolle als
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken im
deutschen bundestag den kapitalismus
überwinden werden wir heute wohl kaum
aber ich bin gespannt wie wir uns finden
wenn es darum geht über eine gerechte
gesellschaft nachzudenken
schön sind sie hier frau wagenknecht
herzlich willkommen sehr gerne frau
wagenknecht wenn ich eines morgens
erwacht und die gesellschaft ist gerecht
woran bemerke ich das ja ich glaube
nicht also so sein wird dass man eines
morgens erwacht man muss schon was dafür
tun aber das wesentliche wäre einfach
dass die gesellschaft nicht mehr so
auseinander driftet das wir nicht diese
extreme kluft haben wobei einigen sich
ihre reichtümer häufen und andere
wirklich von monat zu monat kämpfen
müssen wie sie mit ihren einkommen
tatsächlich ihre wesentlichen ausgaben
bestreiten ihre miete ihren strom ihre
ernährung und viele sogar wirklich auch
bis hin zur ernährung sparen müssen sich
keinen urlaub mehr leisten können und
das darauf einfach nicht so weitergehen
eine gleichere gesellschaft ist das eine
gerechtere gesellschaft der
gerechtigkeit hat natürlich auch etwas
damit zu tun dass menschen
aufstiegschancen haben natürlich sind
menschen nicht ganz gleich also wenn
schon um unterschiedliche talente haben
unterschiedliche fähigkeiten aber die
gesellschaft muss ihnen die chance geben
das was sie an catalent unfähigkeit
haben auch zu entwickeln und davon gut
leben zu können und das ist ja zum
beispiel eines der großen versprechen
des kapitalismus gewesen dass die
menschen aufstiegschancen bekommen dass
jeder sich nach oben arbeiten kann aber
dieses versprechen ist ja inzwischen
völlig hohl völlig unglaubwürdig weil es
eigentlich inzwischen wieder zurückgeht
zu einer gesellschaft wurde ich hier
kommt das meiste bestimmt also ob man
reich ist oder ob man arm ist hängt
heute sehr sehr stark davon ab aus
welcher familie man kommt also wie in
alten zeiten
gleichzeitig ist es aber jetzt im
vergleich zu alten zeiten wenn man
die zeit des absolutismus nimmt ist es
erwiesen dass sie ungefähr 20 mal höhere
aufstiegschancen haben nach damals ja
aber ich würde nicht gerne den maßstab
der absolutismus nehmen sondern ich
würde zum beispiel maßstab nehmen selbst
der nachkriegszeit in westeuropa gab es
ja doch für viele die aus kleinen
verhältnissen kamen aus arbeiterfamilien
kam die chance dann auch zu studieren
und tatsächlich auch dann ein gutes
leben zu führen und heute gehen ja die
wenigsten davon aus und zwar aus gutem
grund dass ihre kinder ist eins besser
haben sondern auch schon heute ist es so
dass die ältere generation und die
mittlere generation in der regel immer
noch gesicherte bessere
arbeitsverhältnisse hat als die jungen
das heißt wir müssen heute davon
ausgehen den jeweiligen kindern geht es
schlechter als den eltern und ich finde
das ist ein ausweis einer kranken
ordnung eines kranken systems also wenn
eine gesellschaft sich technologisch
weiterentwickelt und trotzdem die
nächsten generationen schlechter leben
als die vorangegangenen
dann läuft irgendetwas ganz schief kann
sie vorhin diese krasse ungleichheit
erwähnt die ist auch in ihrem neuen buch
reichtum ohne gleich am anfang erwähnt
diese studie von oxfam die ja gesagt hat
62 personen sehr sehr reiche personen
besitzen gleiche wie die hälfte der
menschheit ist denn wie sie trotzdem
noch einmal gefragt gleichheit ein wert
an sich fragt was deswegen weil der
philosoph harry frankfurt in seinem
neuen buch ungleichheit jetzt das buch
basiert zwar auf alten aufsatz trotzdem
ein neues kleines buch betonte er das
eigentlich ungleichheit nicht wirklich
ein problem darstellt und gleichheit
keinen wert an sich beim hatte sich zum
beispiel eine sehr gleiche gesellschaft
vorstellen nämlich eine klinik eine
gesellschaft in der alle gleich wenig
haben daher am verhungern sind ja keine
gute gesellschaft ja das wäre sicher
keine gute gesellschaft aber das
argument dass die ungleichheit auch die
schwächsten nach oben zieht das ist ja
ein argument was für die vergangenheit
für bestimmte phasen vielleicht
zutreffend war also natürlich hat der
kapitalismus in den 200 250 jahren
seiner existenz sehr viel reichtum
geschaffen und es geht heute einem
normalen arbeiter natürlich besser als
im 19 jahrhundert aber inzwischen haben
wir eine ungleichheit die die schere
immer weiter öffnet dh
inzwischen steigen die mittelschichten
ab also die große ungleichheit zieht die
unteren nicht mehr hoch sondern es
drückt sie nach unten also die
mittelschicht erodiert und die ärmeren
werden noch ärmer selbst in den
reichsten ländern
und das zeigt dass dieses argument wir
brauchen viel ungleichheit damit es uns
allen besser geht ist ein verlogenes
argument das ist auch eine ideologie man
hat ja damit auch eine bestimmte politik
gerechtfertigt nämlich eine politik die
reiche steuerlich entlastet hat weil man
gesagt hat man muss die sich entfalten
lassen man darf sie nicht immer
steuerlich so stark belasten
man hat auch löhne gesenkt mann hat in
deutschland zum beispiel mit der agenda
2010 einen riesigen niedriglohnsektor
geschaffen mit dem argument dann würde
sich die wirtschaft besser entwickeln
die wirtschaft die gewinne haben sich
besser entwickelt aber den menschen geht
es schlechter es heißt ihr buch ja eben
reichtum ohne gier machen sie damit
nicht so was wie eine implizite
unterstellung dass die reichen haben
sich schwierig sind
ich denke es gibt jährige reiche es gibt
auch nicht gierige und sehr anständige
reiche die frage ist nur beruht der
reichtum auf eigener leistung auf
eigenem also das was man der
gesellschaft gegeben hat ist das
sozusagen durch den reichtum belohnt
worden oder beruht der leistung auf der
arbeit anderer und wir haben heute ein
reichtum der in extremer größenordnung
darauf beruht dass andere für einen
arbeiten also niemand kann aus eigener
leistung hunderte millionen oder gar
milliarden vermögen erarbeiten oft sind
sehr erbt also meiner erbt aktienpakete
man ererbt betriebsvermögen und die
vermehren sich weil natürlich
großunternehmen eben in der regel auch
sehr sehr gewinnträchtig sind und oft
ist es auch so dass diejenigen die die
eigentümer sind ja längst nicht mehr die
unternehmen führen sondern die machen
tatsächlich wie früher der alte adel so
seine freunde kassiert hat kassieren sie
völlig leistungs los extrem hohe
einkommen während dessen die die
arbeiten eben oft sehr schlecht für ihre
leistung bezahlt werden
dabei ziehen sie sich auch auf den
ökonomen thomas pikett der diese
ungleichheit auch angetan hat hat und
auch immer wieder darauf hinweist dass
eigentlich reichtum heute vor allem
vererbt wird oder man heiratet sich in
eine reiche familien an irgend wie
früher wie sie auch sagen ich finde
interessant dass sie als sozialistin
eigentlich hingehen
sagen na ja wir brauchen wieder so was
wie ein leistungsgedanken man muss heute
doch eigentlich wieder dafür sorgen dass
die leute das was sie besitzen
erarbeiten
ja ich finde das ist doch ein ei nur
linke anspruch also ich habe nie
verstanden dass menschen in kapitalismus
dafür kritisieren dass sie sagen er sei
eine leistungsgesellschaft und das
negativ konnotierten sondern dass
menschen für ihre leistung belohnt
werden ist ja etwas sehr positives und
das problem besteht darin mehr leistung
nicht mehr durch entsprechendes
einkommen sich niederschlägt und nicht
leistung also zum beispiel aber ist ja
nun wirklich keine leistung am ende zu
enormen start vorteilen führt natürlich
muss es eine gesellschaft immer eine
balance wahren und natürlich wenn jemand
krank ist wenn jemand in bestimmten
bereichen nicht leistungsfähig ist dann
muss die gesellschaft ihn auffangen also
ich will ja keine ellenbogen
gesellschaft wo jetzt wirklich nur die
taffen und fitten nach oben kommen
aber wer den kapitalismus so beschreibt
als sei es eine solche gesellschaft das
sozusagen nur die smartesten die
intelligentesten das sind dann auch die
wohlhabenden der beschuldigten also der
der league unterliegt auch eine mythos
weil es ist eben einfach nicht so und
vor allem wende über leistung reden muss
man eben auch darüber reden wie befähigt
man menschen ihre für ihre eigenen
talente zu entwickeln da ist ein ganz
anderes bildungssystem notwendig also
dass armut so erblich ist ist ja nicht
weil die menschen also weil ein kind
eines armen eben weniger geistige
kapazitäten hat sondern oft genug weil
schon in der schule die auslese sehr
früh stattfindet und diese kinder gar
nicht die chance bekommen ihre
fähigkeiten wirklich entwickeln zu
können also ich würde sagen jeder möchte
eigentlich gerne gleich viel leisten nur
jeder kann nicht gleiche leisten da die
voraussetzungen nicht so sind ich glaube
jeder kann unterschiedliches leisten
also jeder mensch hat meines erachtens
in bestimmten bereichen oder irgendeinem
bereich eine fähigkeit wo er tatsächlich
überdurchschnittliches leisten kann
er muss nur die chance bekommen erst mal
diese diesen bereich zu entdecken und
sich dort auch zu qualifizieren also
deswegen halte ich auch gar nichts von
diesen theorien die jetzt sagen ja ein
großteil der menschheit ist geil wird
gar nicht mehr gebraucht in zukunft die
digitalisierung rationalisiert die jobs
weg jeder mensch wird gebraucht weil
jeder mensch etwas kann
aber man muss ihm auch die mittel geben
also natürlich ist ein kind nicht von
vornherein ein hochbegabter violinist
wenn es nie in seinem leben eine bio
linien die hand bekommt und ähnlich ist
es ja auch bei mathematik physik
also es muss ja erstmal eine nennt
grundwissen vermittelt werden erst dann
merkt man dass man es karten und bei
überforderten schulen bei der großen
schulklassen oder wo heute zum beispiel
auch studium wieder zunimmt eine
finanzielle frage wird da ist dann eben
der eigene bildungsweg gar nicht mehr
durch die eigene fähigkeit bestimmt und
dann natürlich auch nicht mehr die
chance sich mit eigener leistung
wirklich ein gutes lebenseinkommen auch
zu verdienen sie sind ja eine person die
enorm viel leistet sie sind sehr aktiv
wo in den unterschiedlichsten feldern
eben aus fraktionsvorsitzende der partei
die linke im bundestag sie kämpfen schon
sehr sehr lange eigentlich für eine
gerechtere welt genau genommen
eigentlich wirklich schon seit ihren
teenagerjahren sie sind in der ddr groß
geworden haben schon ganz früh marx und
hegel gelesen und auch ganz viele andere
dinge sind dann nach dem fall der mauer
der pds beigetreten also der
nachfolgepartei der ddr der sed und in
diesem ganzen kontext haben sie immer
dieses dieses feuer an den tag gelegt
für eine gerechte gesellschaft zu
kämpfen
woher haben sie diese kampfeslust
verwandt nicht also ich finde einfach
der mensch hat es nicht verdient unter
verhältnissen zu leben die in demütigen
die ihm seine chancen nehmen oder die
zumindest für einen großteil der
bevölkerung wirklich schlechtere
lebensverhältnisse bedeuten als es heute
möglich wäre also wir werden ja
technologisch tatsächlich immer reicher
und es ist ja so dass es auch immer mehr
gäbe was verteilt wäre und menschenleben
trotzdem unter solcher enger also ich
muss sagen ich geh ich leide das auch
leidet damit wenn ich da einfach solche
fälle sehe auch im persönlichen
bekanntenkreis wo menschen am ende auch
krank werden weil sie zum beispiel lange
in die arbeitslosigkeit gedrängt werden
immer nur befristete jobs bekommen mit
dem ganzen stress und diese angst auch
dann nicht klarkommen wie es weitergeht
oft an schulden haben und irgendwann
fangen sie an zu trinken und gehen
kaputt und
das muss doch einfach nicht sein zu
erwähnen sie ihr persönliches umfeld ich
habe mir aber gerade gedacht
sie sind als berufspolitikerin autorin
sieht auch ein gern gesehener gast in
talkshows sehr viel unterwegs
unglaublich beschäftigt verheiratet mit
oskar lafontaine der auch sozusagen in
der wolle gewaschener linker ist das
heißt da werden sie jetzt auch nicht am
abend das gegenprogramm hören zu ihren
ansichten wo haben sie eigentlich
kontakt mit sagen gemalt den opfern des
kapitalismus also einmal dadurch dass
ich natürlich zu ganz vielen
veranstaltungen gehe aus mit
unterschiedlichen einladungen also dass
ich nicht alles opfer natürlich wenn ich
an der universität bin spreche ich damit
studenten die sind per se jetzt erstmal
nicht opfer aber natürlich sagen die mir
welche ängste sie haben und in
deutschland ist es inzwischen ja so auch
ein akademiker
gerade junge leute haben zunehmend nur
noch befristete jobs und auch an der uni
selber sind ja jetzt wirklich teilweise
riesige niedriglohn zonen entstanden wo
menschen wirklich anspruchsvollste
arbeiten machen in der forschung in der
lehre und dafür einen hunger gehalt
bekommen oder ich gehe natürlich zu
gewerkschaften ich gehe zur
arbeitsloseninitiativen
ich spreche mit menschen die in der
leiharbeit sind und da bekommt man das
ja ganz unmittelbar mit oder letztens
war ich an einer berufsschule wo auch
menschen junge leute gesagt haben ja
eigentlich wissen sie gar nicht sie
machen jetzt diese lehre und sie wollen
dass auch abschließen aber sie haben
eigentlich extreme angst wie sie ihr
berufsleben gestalten und schon diese
ganz jungen machten sich auch sorgen wie
sie im alter leben sollen also die rente
in deutschland ist ja weitgehend
zerstört die gesetzliche rente und die
meisten verdient nicht so viel dass sie
irgendwie sparen können
jetzt gibt es aber die schwierigkeit die
gibt es wahrscheinlich in sehr vielen
ländern die dem wir auch in der schweiz
sehen wir in vielen europäischen ländern
dass gerade diejenigen personen die
sozusagen die linken parteien eben
beschützen oder retten wollen je nachdem
welche terminologie wählen
schlussendlich gar nicht die linke
wählen oder die sozialdemokraten wählen
sondern neuerdings zum beispiel fti
also das hat natürlich auch mit dieser
verunsicherung zu tun also die leute
haben ängste sie wissen nicht also sie
fühlen sich von der politik im stich
gelassen und sie haben natürlich ganz
oft die erfahrung gemacht dass sie
verschiedene parteien wählen
und die am ende alle die gleiche politik
machen also in deutschland ist ja die
die hauptquelle der deregulierung und
auch der arbeitnehmerfeindliche politik
tatsächlich losgetreten worden unter
einer rot grünen regierung also mit spd
und grünen
und natürlich werden wir oft dann auch
noch als teil dieser parteien gesehen
als teil der etablierten parteien wo wir
sicherlich auch selber schuld haben wenn
wir uns nicht klar genug wie schon
gesagt ich anderen linken sozusagen die
anderen linken sie nicht schon wir sind
mit schuld weil wir uns nicht genug von
ihnen abgegrenzt haben aber natürlich
ist das auch immer ein indikator wenn
sozialdemokratische parteien dann eine
arbeitnehmerfeindliche politik machen
eine politik geben gegen die ärmeren
dass die leute dann nicht noch weiter
nach links gehen nämlich zu uns sondern
dass sie dann aus ihrer situation heraus
nach rechts gehen zumal die rechten
lösungen scheinbar einfache lösungen
sind also es ist ja der mensch hat eben
immer auch alle eigenschaften irgendwo
in in sich also hat auch immer die
neigung nach unten zu treten oder zu
hoffen dass noch einer unter ihm ist was
ihm dann ein gewisses gefühl der
bestätigung gibt und genau so ist
natürlich was die rechten bedienen also
hast auf flüchtlinge hass auf menschen
anderer nationalität
das ist dann da ist dann oft auch ein
fruchtbarer boden aber ich finde wir
müssen uns als linke fragen warum wir
diese menschen nicht genug erreichen
also es ist nicht so lange anderen die
frage ist ja dann immer wie weit links
soll man denn weitergehen
und in diesem kontext wurde ihnen ja
immer wieder vorgeworfen dass sie zu
links stehen würden man hat ihn lange
immer wieder gesagt sie würden zu wenig
sich abgrenzen vom stalinismus sie
würden zu wenig sich abgrenzen von der
ddr aus diktatorischen system und in
diesem kontext gab es auch in der
schweiz eine episode da hat man groß
darüber diskutiert sie wurde nämlich im
jahr 2000 eingeladen als festrednerin
des ersten mai komitees und selbst das
erste mai komitee war damals gespalten
die linke in der schweiz war gespalten
weil sie eben einigen linken zu links
waren und die rundschau hat dann hat ein
porträt gebracht aber sie schauen wir
uns ein paar bilder daraus an
das ist mein arbeitszimmer auf der seite
sehen sagen vor allem so die literatur
die ich wenn ich mich entspannen oder
wenn ich mich irgendwie wieder
regenerieren will leese also die ganze
beim raw ausgabe der goethe werke
shakespeare peter hacks diese neigen zu
die sachen die ich mit freude und mit
genuss lese das lese ich auch mit genuss
aber natürlich mehr aus
wissenschaftlichem interesse marx lenin
auch rosa luxemburg wie würden sie sich
denn selbst politisch einordnen als
marxisten und aus kommunisten ist das
zeitgemäß
ich denke mehr denn je also gerade wenn
wir uns ansehen wie diese welt
beschaffen ist wie die kontraste immer
größer werden wir auf der einen seite
immer mehr leute auf der straße sitzen
junge leute waren zunächst in die
millionen von leuten gestorben ja gut
die frage ist ja wahr des kommunismus
also unter stalin das würde ich also
auch nicht in ansätzen nicht mal als
sozialismus ansehen schon allein weil
die ökonomische grundlagen für
sozialismus gar nicht da waren
kommunismus war das natürlich erst recht
nicht in berlin schreibt sarah warten
nicht an ihrer dissertation über karl
marx sie verteidigt den realen
sozialismus der ddr kritisiert man ihre
heimat als spitzelstaat dann konnte sie
mit den sozialen errungenschaften
trotzdem gab es eine soziale sicherheit
die sich heute viele wieder wünschen
trotzdem war es keine lappalie dass zum
beispiel kinder kein armutsrisiko waren
wie heute dass man gesundheit und
krankheit sich nicht an persönlichen
geldbeutel ab rechnen musste das heißt
existenzängste angst den arbeitsplatz zu
verlieren angst dass die kinder auf der
straße sitzen nach dem schulabschluss
solche ängste gab es nicht und das kann
man auch nicht nivellieren
dadurch dass man sagt es gab eben
daneben die stasi und es gab also sehr
viele unerfreuliche dinge soziale
errungenschaften der ddr
finden sie dass nach wie vor so frau
wagenknecht also natürlich gab es eine
soziale sicherheit nur trotzdem möchte
ich in dieses system nicht zurück ich
habe auch früher glaube ich den fehler
gemacht aus einem gewissen trotz heraus
weil die ddr natürlich unmittelbar
nachdem sie zu recht gescheitert war von
vielen die sie vorher vertreten und
verteidigt hatte dann in bausch und
bogen wirklich in die tonne getreten
wurde habe ich damals so irgendwie
dachte jetzt muss ich weil ich linke bin
diese ddr verteidigen das war wirklich
unsinn
ich meine natürlich war das ein system
das wirtschaftlich nicht funktioniert
das auch wirklich brutale weise eben
auch meinungsfreiheit unterdrückt hat
nun ja selber eigentlich fast ein
bisschen auch ein stückweit opfer
gewesen das ist nämlich kein
studienplatz haben ja ja ich habe ja
auch alle lieben wie dich gepasst haben
zum kollektiv unglaubliches begründung
was ist das für eine geschichte
ja also das ist ja auch immer so
merkwürdig wenn mir dann zum beispiel
von cdu mitgliedern in deutschland
vorgeworfen wird ich sei eine ddr
verteidigerin
die deutsche bundeskanzlerin war
wesentlich systemkonforme hat also fdj
funktion gehabt hat karriere gemacht
währenddessen ich ja schon zu ddr zeiten
sehr viel marx gelesen hatte und ich
habe mich als sozialistin verstanden und
gerade deshalb vieles an der ddr
kritisiert und mich da auch dagegen
gewandt und wo ich dann wirklich auch
einen konflikt hat war beispielsweise es
gab in der ddr so eine vormilitärische
ausbildung wo auch mädchen hin mussten
in ein lager wo man dann im
gleichschritt marschieren und gasmaske
tragen und alle so furchtbare dinge tun
musste und ich habe das einfach
überhaupt nicht ausgehalten also einmal
weil ich das militärische abgelehnt habe
zum anderen weil ich auch völlig absurd
fand für einen krieg zu proben von dem
klar war das ding kein mensch überleben
kann
also es wäre ja damals quasi der dritte
weltkrieg gewesen und habe mich dann da
verweigert habe dann auch nichts mehr
gegessen also was mir auch wirklich
schlecht ging in diesem lager und bin
dann sozusagen eben mit diesem ausweis
also die kann sich nicht ins kollektiv
einen einordnen
tatsächlich nicht zum studium zugelassen
worden obwohl ich eigentlich ein sehr
gutes abitur hatte hatte dann zunächst
so eine sekretärin stelle die habe ich
gelegentlich auch nicht gefahren genau
dann haben sie glaube ich nachrichten
habe ich zu hause war ich zu hause haben
nachhilfestunden gegeben weil ich ja von
irgendetwas leben musste und habe dann
allerdings in dem jahr also 88 habe ich
abitur gemacht
bis anfang 1990 unglaublich viel gelesen
also ich hatte natürlich sehr viel zeit
aber es war trotzdem keine schöne
situation weil ich natürlich nicht
wusste wie es weitergeht ich wusste
nicht ob ich jemals an einer uni komme
ich hatte keine kommunikation also ich
habe alles nur in mich reingefressen was
spannend war was mich später auch also
im studium natürlich mir sehr viel
geholfen hat
aber nicht alles gelesen hatte von
blasen sie heute immer noch shakespeare
uns gehörte zu entspannen wie in dem
beitrag gerne ja also leider nicht mehr
so oft weil ich eben wirklich nicht mehr
so viel zeit habe aber gerade goethe ist
bei goethe schaue ich immer mal wieder
rein weil das einfach so spannend
aktuelles also zb der faust ist ein so
aktuelles werk wenn man den faust 2 ließ
ist ja im grunde auch schon die ganze
widersprüchlichkeit des kapitalismus
also faust wird ja zum schluss zum
unternehmer schafft reichtum wohlstand
macht land urbar und gleichzeitig ja ist
ja für schlimme verbrechen
verantwortlich also es ist ja der mord
an philemon und baucis ist die ganze
dialektik mit mephistopheles wo er sich
dann ab setzt und was wirklich finde ich
wunderschön ist es dann würde der
schluss wo mephisto im grunde sich dann
in diese engel verliebt und dadurch
voraus seele ihm entglitten ist oder ihm
entgleitet was ja wirklich so eine
hommage an die hände an die menschheit
ist also eine liebeserklärung eigentlich
daran was was menschen doch trotz aller
verbrechen ihre geschichte dass sie es
wirklich wert sind
eine positive zukunft zu haben sie sind
es eben in ihrer meinung wert dem
kapitalismus zu entrinnen ihr buch heißt
eben reichtum ohne gier und der titel
darüber wie die uns vor dem kapitalismus
retten
interessant ist ja daran wenn man so die
idee hat man muss sich vor dem
kapitalismus retten dass es den
kapitalismus des 19 jahrhunderts den
marx kritisierte eigentlich soll ja gar
nicht mehr gibt es sind ja nicht immer
ein stück weit mischformen zwischen
kapitalistischen und sagen wir
sozialistischen strukturelementen die
sich jetzt in einer sozialen
marktwirtschaftlichen die verschwistert
haben aber sie sagen oder so verstehe
ich sie ein stück weit ist die
globalisierung mit schuld daran dass
dieser kapitalismus zu einer sohn hat
toxischen mischung werden konnte warum
ist die globalisierung sozusagen so eine
treibende kraft die den kapitalismus
endgültig zum kippen bringt ob sie zum
kippen bringt es ja was haben das
segantini verleger thema erstmal da ja
weil sie einfach bestimmte also man
hatte ja nach dem zweiten weltkrieg ist
eigentlich geschafft in allen großen
industriestaaten im kapitalismus relativ
starke soziale zügel anzulegen
es gab eben den wohlfahrtsstaat es gab
ausgebaute sozialsysteme und das hat
natürlich alles die renditen verringert
aber die lebensverhältnisse der menschen
deutlich verbessert hat ja ein langes
eine lange phase des wachstums gegeben
und die globalisierung ist ja auf der
einen seite politisch gemacht also man
hat ja die schleusen geöffnet aber sie
hat auf der anderen seite den
unternehmen natürlich dann auch eine
macht gegeben ihre interessen in den
einzelnen ländern durchzusetzen wie sie
so vorher nicht hatten also ganze
staaten werden ja press war
wenn ein großes unternehmen eben darüber
entscheidet ob es im staat war oder im
staat b investiert ob es betriebsteile
verlagert wo ist seine steuern zahlt
also alles das hat also man hat die
machtverhältnisse haben sich verschoben
die politik hatte plötzlich nicht mehr
die hoheit über die wirtschaft sondern
die wirtschaft vor allem die großen
konzerne haben sich die hoheit über die
politik und über die gesamte
gesellschaft zurückgeholt die
finanzmärkte haben eine ganz andere
macht bekommen heute entscheiden
irgendwelche finanzspekulanten und
investmentbanker welchem zins als einen
staat zu zahlen hat und damit ist
natürlich eigentlich auch jede
demokratie ausgehebelt sie sagen so
etwas wie die wirtschaft hat sich
globalisiert die demokratie ist aber ein
stück weit lokal geblieben
darauf gibt es ja zwei antworten man
könnte entweder sagen dann lasst uns
auch die wirtschaft wieder lokal machen
oder man könnte sagen dann lasst uns die
demokratie globalisieren sprich die eu
zb stärken sie plädieren dafür dass
umgekehrt die sie wollen gerne die
wirtschaft wieder kleinteiliger machen
ja weil ich glaube dass angriff
funktioniert nicht weil demokratie
braucht überschaubare räume und wenn der
raum zu groß wird also ein land ein
staat das ist überschaubar
also ich finde zum beispiel gibt die
schweiz ist ja ein beispiel zumindest
selbst werden dann nicht einem jedes
ergebnis gefällt aber eine
funktionierende demokratie weil man
immer sehr stark ja immer die diskussion
gibt es nicht die tyrannei der mehrheit
zum beispiel ja aber ich finde also dann
muss man darüber reden wie man mit
bildung oder eben mit demokratischen
medien tatsächlich auch eine öffentliche
diskussion zulässt aber für mich ist
demokratie keine tyrannei sondern also
ist ja die partner in der mehrheit wäre
ja eigentlich dass die mehr als sich
durchsetzt natürlich muss es eben auch
minderheitenrechte geben aber ich
wünsche mir schon dass die mehrheit
politik bestimmen und was wir
tatsächlich in den meisten ländern haben
ist ja eben nicht eine politik für die
mehrheit sondern eine politik für eine
sehr kleine minderheit in der regel für
die oberen 1 prozent und je größer die
strukturen werden zum beispiel auch die
europäische ebene desto weniger hat die
bevölkerung eine chance irgendwie zu
kontrollieren was die politischen
akteure dort machen so rosig denn der
überschaubaren rahmen die ihnen eine
demokratie noch bewältigen kann
ich glaube das hat mit mit historie zu
tun also ob es eine gemeinsame
politische kultur gibt die gibt es in
den nationalstaaten an dich weil das
irgendwie nationalstaaten sind sondern
einfach weil es historisch gewachsene
staaten sind da können ja sehr
unterschiedlichen nationen in diesen
staaten leben aber da gibt es parteien
die sind zuordenbar
wie unterscheiden sich oft viel weniger
als man sich das wünschen würde aber
zumindest weiß man was wir sind auf
europäischer ebene gibt es keine
funktionierende parteien das sind
zusammenschlüsse und im europäischen
parlament gibt es auch keine richtigen
fraktionen das sind völlig heterogene
gruppen ich war ja selber im
europäischen parlament silvana
abgeordnete aber fünf jahre unglücklich
da ja weil der fall ist wirklich kein
leben des parlamentes also das ist kein
parlamentarismus der dort stattfindet
also das heißt nicht dass nicht ab und
an auch mal vernünftige dinge dort
entschieden werden
aber zum beispiel ist es dort so dass
der einfluss der wirtschaftslobby es
viel viel stärker ist als im nationalen
parlamenten einfach weil es keiner
beobachtet also das typische im
europäischen parlament ist zum beispiel
dass in den einzelnen ausschüssen
lobbyisten sitzen und zwar in der regel
mehr lobbyisten als abgeordnete das wäre
im bundestag undenkbar also da kommen
lobbyisten höchstens rein wenn man sie
einlädt zu einer anhörung aber es ist
ganz ausgeschlossen dass in den normalen
ausschusssitzungen lobbyisten dort
sitzen mit schreiben sie haben zwar kein
stimmrecht aber sie machen den großteil
der anträge die dann die abgeordneten
einbringen und ich habe auch gemerkt
wenn man die die art und weise wie
lobbyismus dort auftritt also auch die
schamlosigkeit die direktheit auch das
einkaufen der abgeordneten ist viel viel
massiver als es auf nationaler ebene
möglich wäre
und das ist dass ich oben eigentlich ein
stück weit wieder den nationalstaaten
das ist erstmal ja wirklich sehr
erstaunlich main der internationalismus
ist also was wir die heilige kuh der
linken und jetzt tragen sie die quasi
zur schlachtbank
nein das werde ich auf gar keinen fall
ich will und möchte dass wir
international denken dass wir eine
internationale kultur haben dass wir uns
europa erfüllen natürlich aber ich sehe
ja ich sehe dass die eu eigentlich
gerade diese europäische identität
aktuell kaputt macht die die bevölkerung
werden doch immer mehr gegeneinander
gestellt und sie assoziieren oftmals mit
brüssel den druck löhne zu senken renten
zu kürzen öffentliche ausgaben zu kürzen
weil diese eben so strukturiert dass
auch mit ihren verträgen mein wir haben
eu-verträge da gibt es keine auflage an
die einzelnen länder dass sie die
armutsquote senken müssen dass sie die
arbeitslosigkeit bekämpfen müssen alles
das ist überhaupt ein völlig offen
das einzige was als auflage den ländern
gemacht wird ist dass sie ihre defizite
reduzieren
gleichzeitig ist die eu unfähig oder
unwillig also mit herrn junker ist das
jetzt nicht erstaunlich zb die
steuersysteme so zu vereinheitlichen
dass wenigstens innerhalb der eu nicht
ein steuerdumping stattfindet wo große
unternehmen sich wirklich die besten
modelle aussuchen können und ihre
steuerquote auf drei prozent drücken und
die videos von denen könnte ja auch eine
sagen die rechtskonservative partei
unterschreiben wo sagen sie hinsichtlich
internationalismus jetzt da unterscheide
ich mich aber ich bin nicht rechts
konservativ nein das finde ich ganz
sicher nicht weil ich will nicht dass
nationale um des nationalen willens und
ich finde es ziemlich borniert wenn
irgendwie eine ideologie verfochten wird
dass einzelne völker irgendwie fleißiger
oder oder besser oder was weiß ich sind
als andere also wir haben zum beispiel
in deutschland wirklich eine ganz üble
debatte gehabt als es um die
griechenland pakete ging die ja wirklich
griechenland nichts genützt haben
sondern nur den banken aber diese
riesigen summen an steuergeld die dort
akquiriert wurden und das wurde mit
einer debatte verbundenen von wegen die
faulen griechen die können es doch nicht
und das ist gerade das was ich finde wo
man die menschen gegeneinander aufbringt
ich möchte auch europäische
zusammenarbeit also ich würde mir zum
beispiel regeln in der steuerpolitik
wünschen die verhindern dass unternehmer
und vermögende gerade ihre steuern
reduzieren können während der normale
beschäftigte oder der konsumenten
kann man natürlich immer zurück zur
kasse bitten also ich möchte ein europa
das zusammenarbeitet aber ich möchte
nicht diese eu strukturen die von
lobbyisten der großen unternehmen
dominiert werden und deren politik auch
so aussieht also es ist ja vor allem das
was aus brüssel kommt oft fragt man sich
ja warum kommt eine bestimmte
regulierung wenn man genau hinguckt ist
irgendeine lobby dazu gange gewesen die
auf jeden fall davon profitiert und es
sind immer konzern lobbys sie sich dort
durchsetzen und das ist natürlich eine
politik gegen die mehrheit der menschen
auch gegen kleine unternehmen
der vordenker der dass das post
kapitalismus paul mason sein buch ist
gerade auf deutsch erschienen im
suhrkamp verlag post kapitalismus ein
ganz schiller und denker der sagt ganz
klar dass der falsche weg wir müssen
unbedingt aufhören zu denken wir sollten
die ökonomie wieder nationaler gestalten
und zwar genau also einen gedanken
heraus der ihnen eigentlich wichtig ist
nämlich aus den gedanken der gleichen
chancen heraus weil alle die menschen
die jetzt bis anhin nicht teilhaben
konnten an dem auf der kapitalismus
vielleicht doch brauchte die haben
nämlich keine chance aufzuholen wenn wir
jetzt wieder die ökonomie zurückdrängen
in die länder sondern wir müssen schauen
dass die globalisierung fange mal
gerettet wird was ihr daraus die guten
ideen herausziehen und dazu gehört eben
auch die ökonomie weiterhin global zu
denken
nein das sehe ich ganz anders sondern
ich glaube dass gerade auch ärmere
länder unter der globalisierung leiden
also wir zwingen ja zum beispiel gerade
ländern in afrika sie bezwingen sie dazu
dass die freihandelsabkommen
unterschreiben dass sie ihre märkte
öffnen und die konsequenz ist überall
das die lokale industrie kaputtgeht wir
exportieren unsere subventionierten
agrargüter in länder wo natürlich die
bauern vor ort keine chance haben
wettbewerbsfähig zu sein das heißt auch
diese länder würden profitieren wenn sie
ihre märkte schließen würden und die
wenigen großen erfolgs storys der
globalisierung das sind nun ausgerechnet
länder die ihr genau nicht das gemacht
haben was der neoliberalen mainstream
eigentlich sagt nämlich sich öffnen
alles deregulieren also china zum
beispiel oder südkorea sondern die haben
ja im grunde ein völlig anderes modell
ein ganz stark staatlich regulierten
kapitalismus natürlich auch verbunden
mit einer politischen diktatur also sind
natürlich auch keine demokratie
aber sie haben eben gerade sich nicht
den märkten geöffnet sie haben auch
nicht unbegrenzt kapital ins land
gelassen sondern das sehr sehr
kontrolliert gemacht und nur deshalb
haben sie zumindest wirtschaftlich
natürlich einen tatsächlichen erfolg
vorzuweisen
aber trotzdem ist es so dass zum
beispiel dann dieser moyo eine
vordenkerin jetzt die für afrika spricht
die sagt entwicklungszusammenarbeit
entwicklungshilfe ist eine schwierigkeit
und natürlich sind ganz viele ganz viele
regeln des globalen marktes ungerecht
und nachteile genau richtig beschrieben
haben aber die lösung ist nicht dass man
sich zurückzieht sondern die lösung wäre
die globalen regeln fair zu gestalten
weil ansonsten haben die länder keine
chance aufzuholen
aber ich glaube in einem markt also
märkte tendieren natürlich dazu auch
immer die starken noch stärker zu machen
und wenn man schon riesige unternehmen
hat dann ist natürlich die chance in
diesen ländern eigene unternehmen
dagegen aufzubauen relativ geringen also
wie gesagt einige länder haben es
dadurch gemacht dass der staat
investiert hat also gerade in
südostasien sind unternehmen hochgezogen
worden durch staatliche investitionen
staatliche kredit lenkung
dadurch hat es da tatsächlich
neueinsteiger gegeben ohne diesen
rückhalt hätte sich dort auch nichts
entwickelt und ich glaube dass man das
beste was man für diese länder machen
kann tatsächlich ist er ist man ihnen
die chance gibt auch eine eigenständige
industrialisierung zu machen
dafür müssen sie sich aber partiell
abschotten gegenüber den importen weil
sonst kann gar nicht etwas eigenes
entstehen
der rückzug liegt das ja nicht aber man
kann sich ja zum beispiel auch die
geschichte in europa angucken also die
die erste und große industrie macht war
großbritannien großbritannien hat immer
für freihandel geworden als sie diese
entwicklung schon hatten weil sie
natürlich damit sich andere märkte
erobern konnten währenddessen die die
sich danach industrialisieren mussten
auch deutschland oder und weise preußen
damals die einzelnen deutschen länder
haben natürlich hohe zölle erhoben damit
sie eine eigenständige
industrialisierung machen können also
auch der kapitalismus hat sich hinter
zahlen mauern auch in den
industrieländern
immer entwickelt und diese
globalisierung ist für die schwachen
keine hilfe sondern macht sie noch
schwächer ich mein afrika ist in den
letzten jahrzehnten jahr abgestiegen und
nicht aufgestiegen und auch in
lateinamerika ist viel zerstört worden
also sondern dieses diese legende die
globalisierung würde zwar in den
industrieländern die menschen ärmer
machen aber woanders würde sie zu mehr
reichtum führen das stimmt so nicht sie
führt zu größeren kontrasten zu größerer
ungleichheit also auch die zahl wie sie
vorhin landen mit denen 62 die heute so
viel haben wie die hälfte der menschheit
das gab es ja noch nie das war ja noch
nie so extrem aus allen nur wenn es eben
wenn es vielleicht so sieht zwar
auseinander läuft aber trotzdem allen
besser geht und vor allem alle genug
haben dass ich eigentlich die grundidee
von von harry frankfurt wenn alle genug
haben dann muss uns eigentlich diese
extreme ungleichheit nicht so geschäft
ja aber führt dazu dass alle nicht dass
sehr viele nicht genug haben und wenige
so viel haben dass sie eigentlich gar
nicht mehr wissen was sie mit dem vielen
geld anfangen sollen und daneben auch ja
völlig extreme entwicklung also wir
haben ja wirklich auch wenn man so im
aktienmarkt guckt also es blumen die die
super luxusgüter industrien und das
boomen die discounter und alles was in
der mitte ist also auch der normale
mittelstand er hat schwierigkeiten
und das ist doch eine ganz perverse
entwicklung eigentlich sprechen wir
vielleicht gerade über diesen punkt wie
entsteht eigentlich wohlstand reicht uns
haben jetzt gesagt na ja viele länder
haben protektionisten gehabt habe
natürlich zölle erhoben haben
kapitalflüsse eben nicht frei von tieren
lassen gut aber ein anderer punkt ist
auch dass ganz viele wirtschaften groß
geworden sind mit hilfe von migranten
und migrantinnen also migration war sehr
oft gerade auch in deutschland ein
großes befördern des
wirtschaftswachstums und das ist ja auch
so ein knackpunkt gegenwärtig dass viele
kapitalismus kritikerinnen und kritiker
sagen migration ist eigentlich zu einem
problem geworden ist aber eigentlich
auch die kehrseite des kapitalismus auch
das sagen sie ein stück weit und da sind
sie auch nicht alleine da gibt's viele
philosophen dienen beipflichten étienne
balibar ist jemand slavoj zizek an
vorderster front betonen immer wieder
eigentlich kehrseite des kapitalismus
sehen wir jetzt in den flüchtlingsbooten
ja die sind ja auch ausdruck dessen
wenn wir hatten noch nie so viele
flüchtlinge auf dieser welt wie
gegenwärtig also es ja nur ein sehr
kleiner teil der nach europa kommt
weltweit sind über 60 millionen menschen
auf der flucht
und das ist natürlich ergebnis dessen
das ganze gebiete auf diesem erdball
völlig de stabilisiert sind völlig
zerfallen also ich denke nur daran wie
der nahe und mittlere osten heute
aussieht das ist ja auch produkt
natürlich auch westlicher christlicher
die stabilisierung also gerade zum
beispiel der irak krieg hat ja
unheimlich viel dazu beigetragen den
ganzen nahen osten irgendwie aus dem
gleichgewicht zu bringen hat dazu
geführt dass der e s der islamische
staat gegründet wurde der sich dann
ausgedehnt hat jetzt auch in syrien der
bürgerkrieg wäre ja auch nicht gewesen
ohne den irak krieg dann haben wir in
alle diese gäbe es nicht ohne den
kapitalismus ja bei all diesen kriegen
ging es nicht zuletzt um rohstoffe und
absatzmärkte das heißt es waren
sozusagen ureigene wirtschaftsinteressen
kapitalinteressen die diese kriege
angetrieben haben wie man der normale
amerikaner hat kein interesse an diesen
kriegen oder hat auch nichts davon und
der normale europäer schon gar nicht
sondern dass im krieger die tatsächlich
von großen unternehmen auch so sein da
sind die profiteure da sind die
antreiber und natürlich die
rüstungslobby also da ist deutschland
dann auch ganz vorn mit dabei als einer
der haupt scott höheres von waffen gegen
ökonomische interessen haben sie ja
nichts einzuwenden sie sagen ja zum
beispiel die märkte die müssen wir
verbessern aber sie wollen nicht den
markt abschaffen sie wollen zb nicht
zurück zur planwirtschaft oder so etwas
also rein die tatsache dass man zb mit
rohstoffen handeln den setzt ein zeichen
dafür dass sie irgendwie einen ganz
schlimmen kapitalistischen system liege
nein der markt ist ja wenn man das mit
rohstoffen handeln ist nicht das problem
das problem ist dass man militärische
mittel einsetzt um sich den zugang zu
billigen rohstoffen zu verschaffen
und ich glaube wenn wir die geschichte
des kapitalismus sehen ist es eben auch
eine idealisierung zu sagen das waren
sozusagen neutrale märkte die dort sich
sozusagen ausgewirkt haben sondern der
staat hat eine ganz massive rolle und er
hat sie bis heute auch in den usa eben
auch mit seiner militärmaschinerie also
wenn man rohstoffe kauft man kann
natürlich überall öl kaufen aber wenn
man den billigen zugang haben will wenn
man vor allem mit den eigenen
neben öl fördern will im irak in anderen
ländern dann geht man militärisch vor
also das ist gerade das gegenprogramm
zum markt märkte da wo sie funktionieren
da wo sie wirklich auch wettbewerb
leistungswettbewerb ermöglichen da sind
sie unersetzlich also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen wie eine wirtschaft ohne
marktmechanismen funktionieren soll weil
sie natürlich auch ein druck auf die
hersteller ausüben der konsument hat
eine wahlfreiheit wenn der konsument
keine wahlfreiheit hat was ja heute in
vielen bereichen immer weniger hart weil
es wenige große anbieter nur noch gibt
den bestimmten schlüsselbranchen
aber wenn der atem wenn der kunde keine
wahlfreiheit hat dann kriegt er eben
auch schlechte produkte sprechen wir
noch einmal über dieses
migrationsproblem ist etwas was sie auch
sehr und treibt und sie sind da sehr
unzimperlich mit der bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel sie machen mir große
vorwürfe
sie sagen das sei ein absoluter fehler
gewesen diesen deal mit erdogan zu
schließen
wir haben auch einen tweet den wir sehen
oder nicht sind auch hier hier sieht man
einen tweet von ihnen das ist einer von
vielen wo sie merkel direkt angreifen
was hätte merkel denn anders machen
sollen weil grundsätzlich sind sie auch
eine person dieser hat natürlich müssen
wir diesen menschen helfen natürlich
sind das verfolgte menschen und erstmals
sind auch seine grenzen ja etwas wofür
sie eigentlich einstehen müssten
ja aber ich finde es ist wichtig also
ich finde offene grenzen dass menschen
wenn man sich zum beispiel verliebt in
einem anderen land und man geht dort
freiwillig hin da muss man die
möglichkeit haben aber dass menschen in
großer zahl ihre heimat verlassen müssen
und dann eben versuchen nach europa zu
kommen das ist ja vor allem durch kriege
durch wirtschaftliches desaster und
ähnliches und ich finde unsere ziel
sollte sein dass niemand mehr seine
heimat verlassen muss dass niemand mehr
sein also immer nachlegen und dass er zu
hause eine chance auf eine gute
perspektive hat und dass dann sozusagen
migration in dem sinne noch stattfindet
dass man natürlich auch die chance hat
was auch in europa ja so ist man
studiert woanders man fühlt sich da
plötzlich er zu hause dann ist das ja
kein problem aber nicht ausdruck und
nicht aus zwang und das was ich an dem
deal mit der türkei so schäbig finde ist
dass wir uns hier mit jemandem verbünden
selber alles dafür tut dass menschen aus
ihrer heimat vertrieben werden also
erdogan und das türkische regime führen
ja ein blutigen krieg gegen die kurden
und ermorden dort also menschenkinder
schießen dort wahllos in die zivile
bevölkerung und natürlich vertreiben sie
damit auch menschen also wer wäre sicher
leben bilder kann in den türkischen
kurdengebieten sich zur zeit nicht
aufhalten was wäre denn die alternative
gewesen für merkel
also ich finde dass wir eine europäische
lösung brauchen und noch europas wollten
sie doch eigentlich europa eher
schlechten nein ich möchte diese
brüsseler lobbykratie und technokratie
schwächen ich möchte nicht dass wir
aufhören europäische zusammenarbeit so
praktiziert das wünsche ich mir aber ich
sehe nicht gerade die eu-kommission in
ihrer ganzen wirtschafts hörigkeit nicht
als ein motor einer sinnvollen
europäischen politik gemeinsame lösungen
möchte ich und ich finde eigentlich eine
europäische flüchtlingspolitik das wäre
das was ansteht meine erdogan hat ja
auch zum beispiel einen großen anteil
daran dass der krieg in syrien weiter
gehen weil er islamistische terror
banden in syrien finanziert weil er sie
ausrüstet das heißt da packt ihren wir
mit jemanden der mit eine wichtige
ursache dafür ist dass dieser krieg
nicht aufhört dass auch der
waffenstillstand nicht eingehalten wird
und zum beispiel ein ende des
bürgerkrieges in syrien wäre natürlich
der allererste wichtigste schritt dann
könnten die menschen ihre heimat zurück
dann hätten sie da stehen risiken ich
verstehe ihre prinzipien aber hat angela
merkel in dem moment nicht auf einen
humanitären imperativ hin geantwortet
auf eine humanitäre katastrophe
und dann gilt es zuweilen die prinzipien
ja aber ich habe noch nicht eine auf
eine humanitäre katastrophe antworten
indem ich den der sie mit verursacht
dann sozusagen zu meinem verbündeten
machen also das ist so als wenn es
irgendwie schlimmer waldbrände gibt und
ich sage jetzt die wirklich bekämpfen
mit jemandem gemeinsam von dem bekannt
ist dass er eben im wald raucht und
seine kippen hinwirft also es ist
einfach widersprüchlich und das was wir
jetzt quasi wollen von der türkei ist ja
dass sie quasi eine art flüchtlings
gefängnis wird also dass erdogan die
flüchtlinge nicht mehr durch lässt und
dafür bekommt er eben von der eu
rückhalt
das eigene land in eine islamische
diktatur zu führen weil das ist ja
offensichtlich sein ziel das hat er
erzählt
ja gesagt er will den säkularismus
aufkündigen ja unterdrückt die
meinungsfreiheit er verurteilt
journalisten die wirklich nichts anderes
gemacht haben als ihren job nämlich
recherche und dann die veröffentlichung
der recherche
also ich finde das ist einfach zutiefst
unwürdig sich jemanden anzudienen der
auf solche weise agiert also wenn die
türkei jetzt ein weg gehen würde wo man
erkennt sie will sich jetzt sozusagen
tatsächlich rechtsstaatlich aufstellen
akzeptiert die menschenrechte das wäre
ja eine andere situation aber es ist
erkennbar er nutzt das aus um genau den
gegenteiligen weg zu gehen
und jetzt ist die situation aber so in
deutschland gibt es sehr viele
flüchtlinge deutschland hat sehr viele
flüchtlinge aufgenommen und es ist im
moment nicht absehbar wie es weitergeht
sie haben sich aber jetzt in einer art
und weise geäußert wie sie selbst ihre
eigene partei vor den kopf gestoßen
haben sie haben nämlich gesagt ein stück
weit sei völlig klar es gebe
kapazitätsgrenzen in der aufnahme von
flüchtlingen und sie sind so war sogar
so weit gegangen zu sagen ihr gastrecht
missbraucht hat das recht verwirkt das
sind positionen die canon in der schweiz
auch von den rechts konservativen flügel
und sind aussagen die stehen im klaren
gegensatz zur genfer
flüchtlingskonvention
nein also zunächst mal doch war nein
also ich finde gastrecht also ich habe
mich ja belehren lassen dass das als
negativ empfunden wird aber ich habe das
überhaupt nicht negativ gemeint für mich
ist gastrecht etwas sehr hohes also es
gibt auf der einen seite natürlich das
asylrecht das ist ein grundrecht da kann
es auch keine grenzen nicht verwirkt
also das kann man auch nicht verwirkt
wenn man asyl anspruch hat dann hat man
asyl anspruch nur ein großteil der
flüchtlinge ist ja nicht nach dem
asylrecht bei uns und auch die genfer
flüchtlingskonvention hat natürlich
klauseln dass bei schwerwiegenden
straftaten dann tatsächlich auch der
anspruch erlischt und insoweit war das
von mir gar nicht negativ gemeint
sondern ich möchte ja dass wir
gastfreundlich sind aber wir hatten ihm
in deutschland zum beispiel diese
ereignisse in köln nach der
silvesternacht und natürlich hat das
wesentlich dazu beigetragen in der
gesellschaft die stimmung gegen
flüchtlinge kippen zu lassen
und da muss ich doch sagen wenn ich
möchte dass menschen aufgeschlossen
weiterhin auch den flüchtlingen
gegenüber blick den begegnen dann muss
ich verhindern oder muss versuchen
zumindest zu verhindern dass durch
solche vorkommen des
die gesamte stimmung kippt und auch
politisch also das was man im nachgang
gemacht hat man hat das asylrecht ja
wesentlich abgebaut
das waren ja alles prozesse da haben wir
ja auch dagegen gestimmt weil wir das
überhaupt nicht akzeptabel finden die
nur dadurch möglich wurden also ich
denke da ist auch teilweise ich mein ich
muss sagen auch wenn die linke
kritisieren dann akzeptiere ich das und
dann sehe ich auch dass das vielleicht
missverständlich war aber teilweise
haben mich ja dann leute kritisiert die
selber daran beteiligt waren das
asylrecht zu schleifen und dann muss ich
sagen da ist die diskussion eben auch
wirklich nicht ehrlich gelaufen
also ich meinte damit dass wir alles
dafür tun müssen dass solche ereignisse
nicht passieren und da gehört natürlich
auch dazu dass der staat tatsächlich den
menschen auch mehr sicherheit in jeder
muss es grenzen sind die schon erschöpft
nein ich habe nicht da sie erschöpft
sind aber es gibt natürlich für alles
kapazitätsgrenzen also die kapazitäten
sind nie unbegrenzt und das weiß jetzt
einmal natürlich kann deutschland die
menschen integrieren die jetzt in
deutschland nach deutschland gekommen
sind das ist überhaupt kein problem es
ging ja um die frage der zukunft und wie
wie das weitergeht und das war sich
merkel auch vorwerfe ist sie hat im
herbst also inzwischen ja nicht mehr
aber sie hat damals im herbst die
grenzen auf gemacht er hat viele
menschen aufgenommen
aber sie hat überhaupt keinen plan
gehabt wie sie das tatsächlich
strategisch bewältigt sondern im
gegenteil sie hat die städte und
gemeinden weitgehend allein gelassen
wenn es nicht so viele ehrenamtliche
helfer gegeben hätte wäre das chaos
ausgebrochen sie hat strategien aber hat
keine strategien wenn etwas wie ein aber
man muss doch an irgend eine strategie
entwickeln und ich meine strategie ist
ja nicht schwer also natürlich hätte man
in deutschland kurzfristig einfach ein
größeres defizit akzeptieren können und
dadurch den städten und gemeinden die
kosten abnehmen können da wäre überhaupt
kein problem entstanden also deutschland
ist ja nun wirklich ein reiches land
oder man kann natürlich längerfristig
darüber nachdenken höhere reichensteuer
damit nicht die mittelschicht und die
ärmere dafür bezahlen aber wenn man das
alles nicht macht dann ist man dafür
verantwortlich dass die leute
verunsichert sind und letztlich
produziert man damit diesen höhenflug
der afg die ist ja ein produkt dieses
halben jahres vor allem ich fand
interessant in dieser ganzen debatte
etwas zu lesen was nicht komplett
überrascht hat sehr strittig aber
interessant ein aufsatz in der
zeitschrift uhr luft chefredaktor thomas
vanek schreibt in diesem heft der
kapitalisten sei ein humanismus und zwar
bezieht er sich dabei genau auf diese
flüchtlingskrise und er sagt im grunde
genommen sind diese ganzen debatte
darüber wie wir jetzt mit diesen
kapazitätsgrenzen umgehen wir kommen
darf er nicht kommen darf aus welchen
motiven die machen sich eigentlich fest
an irgendwelchen fabrizieren
eigenschaften von menschen bezüglich
kultur religion ethnie pass den mann hat
oder nicht hat also staatsangehörigkeit
während das noch nicht der kapitalismus
humanistisch sei insofern dass er erst
mal einfach sagt alle diejenigen die
etwas beitragen zu einer beitragen
können zu einer gesellschaft die können
auch mitarbeiten wenn man kommt sein
glück versucht sein glück macht
mitarbeiten kann dann ist man herzlich
willkommen und das macht sich eben nicht
fest an kulturellen hintergründen
doch erstmal ein überraschender und gar
nicht so dumme gedanken
nein das ist im grunde dann wirklich so
dieses nützlichkeit prinzip die die uns
nutzen weil sie ausbildung mitbringen
können kommen und die anderen nicht das
ist eigentlich ganze gegenteil vom
ansatz des asylrechts also was wirklich
geht es darum dass jemand der verfolgt
wird was ich dir das recht mal auf der
seite ich möchte man mit ihnen gerne
darüber sprechen was eigentlich aus idee
dahinter steckt aber ich finde dass es
schließen oder nicht schließen dass wir
den kapitalismus verteufeln oder
vielleicht doch was gutes darin sehen
ihr aber gerade dieses gerade dieses
prinzip das wird ja gerade in den
angelsächsischen ländern auch schon
lange gelebt also die die sozusagen sich
als wirtschaftlich verwertbar erweisen
oder von denen man es annimmt die dürfen
kommen die anderen nicht das vergrößert
ja die internationalen unterschiede das
heißt nämlich dass die reichen länder
quasi die bestqualifizierten aus den
ärmeren abwerben
also ich habe vor kurzem eine statistik
gelesen dass inzwischen die hälfte aller
ärzte in den usa und in england
ausländischer herkunft sind das heißt
sie sparen die ausbildungskosten holen
sich die ärzte aus anderen gebieten die
dann natürlich entsprechend stärker
abgehängt sind und ich muss sagen ich
finde es geradezu zynisch wenn man jetzt
sagt also wir wollen bevorzugt hoch
ausgebildete leute aus syrien also zum
beispiel ärzte die ja nun natürlich vor
ort gebraucht werden
also entweder sagt man wir bieten schutz
an für menschen die fliehen weil sie
eben in ihrem leben bedroht sind dann
kann es aber keinen unterschied geben ob
jemand einen arzt oder ein analphabet
oder wald muss ist ja nicht mal dieses
kriterien seien nicht machen jetzt zu
sagen wir wollen nur die gut
ausgebildeten sondern einfach erst mal
dass die grundidee dass der kapitalismus
schon sowas hat in der grundidee dass
jeder mensch sich eben die einbringen
kann und mit werken und dann auch vom
kuchen was kriegen und dass man nicht
guckt auf staatszugehörigkeit zum
beispiel ja aber das ist doch ein
ziemlich billiger trick um auch unter
mac zu betreiben also natürlich sich
leute in bestimmte bereiche zu holen
bedeutet da ist dann das arbeitsangebot
größer ich unterstelle auch dass das in
deutschland eine rolle spielte das
natürlich wir wir hatten ja ein extrem
schlechte lohnentwicklung und auch sehr
sehr viele niedriglohnjobs nach der
jahrtausendwende also und jetzt hatte
sich in einigen bereichen dadurch dass
die deutsche wirtschaft derart viele
exportüberschüsse hat gab es engpässe
oder sind die löhne zumindest etwas
wieder gestiegen
und natürlich wenn man dann möglichst
viele leute dazu holt dann kann man die
löhne wieder nach unten drücken
aber die frage ist ist das wünschenswert
also ich finde das nicht wünschenswert
und ich finde wie gesagt der andere
aspekt dass wir ländern die
qualifiziertesten fachkräfte abwerben
keine sinnvolle strategie wir haben zum
beispiel auch in deutschland der numerus
clausus beim medizinstudium
der ist so hart dass die meisten jungen
leute davon abgeschreckt werden und
medizin zu studieren
nur das heißt wir bilden selber weniger
medizinstudenten aus und holen uns dann
die ärzte aus ländern die sich teuer
diese ausbildung sozusagen dort
finanziert haben das sind doch auch nur
irgendwie beschreiben und die situation
in der schweiz ist natürlich auch so das
gesundheitswesen habe sehr sehr viele
personen aus deutschland die bei uns
arbeiten
ob man das abwerben bezeichnen will wo
man einfach fragen gehen das ist
personenfreizügigkeit menschen kann ich
entscheiden wo sie ihr glück versuchen
ja ich finde zwischen ähnlich
entwickelten ländern ist das auch in
ordnung haben ja auch in europa die die
freizügigkeit wobei auch da natürlich
inzwischen durch die europäische krise
auch eine besondere abwanderung zum
beispiel aus griechenland ein riesiger
zahl sind ärzte abgewandert was
sicherlich die situation im land nicht
verbessert oder portugal
500.000 junge
gut ausgebildete leute sind während der
krise andere in andere europäische
länder abgewandert
dabei ist fast die garantie dass dieses
land zunächst nicht aus der krise
herauskommen
also zwischen gleich entwickelten
ländern die auch beide seiten eine
ähnliche wirtschaftliche performance
haben also eben nicht 1 1 krisenland und
anderes was ständig überschüsse macht
zwischen gleich entwickelten ländern
finde ich sollte ist diese freizügigkeit
geben das war immer in der alten eu oder
alten eg europäische schon worauf sie
hinauswollen und ich gestehe diesen
punkt ist natürlich auch zur
chancengleichheit braucht immer zuerst
ebenso was auch die gleichheit damit man
sich auch entscheiden kann wirklich
schön dass ich dann gleich dass ich ja
auch aus weil es dann immer auch
menschen gibt die eben zum beispiel von
deutschland nach spanien oder von
deutschland nach portugal ziehen und
dann ist das kein kein brain drain also
keinen abzug von von fähigkeiten lassen
sie mich noch einen schritt weiter gehen
etwas was ich wahnsinnig gern noch
einmal mit ihnen aufgreifen wird ist
post kapitalismus paul mason ein punkt
den ja auch ganz stark herausstreicht
ist das angesagt hört auf mit dieser
ganzen idee wir müssen den kapitalismus
jetzt aktiv überwinden weil wir sind da
schon längst angelangt der kapitalismus
beginn schon lange zu zerbröseln der
zerfleddert in unseren eigenen händen
unter anderem zb deswegen weil die
informationstechnologie sich mit dem
kapitalismus überhaupt nicht verträgt
information ist umsonst heute wir haben
heute sehr sehr viele sehr gebildete
menschen und bildung information ist
umsonst das heißt es erstarken ganz ganz
viele gruppen die vorhin in die nichts
zu sagen haben und werden jetzt auch
partizipieren
es gibt neue formen der commons der
allmende es gibt sharing community
entstehen und das alles wird sowieso aus
dem silicon valley heraus sozusagen wird
sich der kapitalismus sowieso überleben
aber das heißt vielleicht müssen wir gar
nicht so sehr kämpfen denn das halte ich
wirklich für eine völlige illusion also
was ich nicht verträgt sind tatsächlich
die digitale ökonomie und der
marktmechanismus weil wir sehen dass in
dem digitalen bereich
auch aufgrund dessen was man
netzwerkeffekt nimmt also eine bestimmte
leistungen werden umso attraktiver je
mehr menschen sie nutzen
dadurch entstehen dort überall
monopolisten also google facebook amazon
das sind ja alles unternehmen die riesig
sind und im grunde globale monopolisten
oder mehr oder weniger monopolisten sind
aber das sind natürlich nur
kapitalistische unternehmen und die
agieren auch ganz uhr kapitalistischen
nämlich profitorientiert und diejenigen
unternehmen die mit ihnen zu tun haben
bekommen das natürlich auch zu spüren
nämlich indem man ihnen schlechte
konditionen diktiert oder auch bei apple
wenn man mit apple als unternehmen sei
es als anbieter einer app oder so
irgendwie geschäfte machen will ist man
immer auf der schlei auf dem
schlechteren partner muss die
geschäftsbedingungen akzeptieren man
bekommt keine kunden das ist alles
richtig dass wir wahrscheinlich sogar zu
gestehen aber als schlimmster
kapitalismus ja nicht eine entstehen
stehen poliert ist entstehen doch
gegenbewegungen aus einem eine sehr
schöne idee ist doch diese idee des
sogenannten posthum also die idee dass
wir alle produzenten und konsumenten
sind wir haben zu hause vielleicht
irgendwann einen die 3d drucker wir
haben software die umsonst runtergeladen
werden kann können uns unsere
ersatzteile für die geräte die wir haben
selber ausdrucken und konstruieren zu
hause sitzen schon den kommen aber
grundsätzlich könnte man doch sagen das
ist eine unversöhnliche klassen
gegensatz den marx immer betont hat
zwischen den einen den polit jahr das
kämpfen muss und dass nichts besitzt und
produktionsmittel und den kapitalisten
die alle produktionsmittel haben boden
maschinen und so weiter der wird
vielleicht eingeebnet durch diese neuen
formen des eben gemeinschaftlichen aber
es ist ja nicht gemeinschaftlich mein
baum können wir so viele sachen jetzt
kostenlos runterladen nur weil das
geschäftsmodell sich verändert hat also
die firmen verdienen auch google zum
beispiel verdient ja nicht damit dass
wir dafür bezahlen dass wir die
suchmaschinen nutzen sondern wir
bezahlen mit unseren daten und das ist
in vielen anderen bereichen auch also
das geschäftsmodell der digitalen
ökonomie ist unsere da zu speichern zu
verwerten zu verkaufen das ist uns dass
cherry ja aber auch die lebt davon
unsere daten zu verwerten zu speichern
und zu verkaufen und das bedeutet dass
ich also sag mal nehme jetzt oder auch
bei amazon wird alles gespeichert weil
bei apple wird alles gespeichert bei
facebook deswegen müssen wir nichts
dafür bezahlen dass wenn facebook
account haben weil dort also endlos
quasi speicherdaten von uns und profile
angelegt werden die natürlich für
krankenversicherungen interessant sind
für kreditgebende banken interessant
sind für arbeitgeber interessant sind
wir werden also gläsern wir sind in
diesen ökonomien gläserne personen die
immer im besten falle personalisierte
werbung noch bekommen da kann man noch
so ok das schadet nicht die kann ich ja
vielleicht wegklicken
aber es ist eben nicht nur die
personalisierte werbung es sind
inzwischen zunehmend auch differenzierte
preise die sich danach richten was
sozusagen welches kaufkraft man jemanden
zutraut und es sind eben auch wirklich
da den handel inzwischen mit
arbeitgebern wo menschen plötzlich
keinen job mehr kriegen weil es ihre
engel facebook die falsch und alle haben
verändern sie jetzt nicht dauernd auf
diese sagen wir mal internetgiganten
natürlich ist dieses problem erkannt
aber es gibt auch schon diese momente wo
man denkt es gibt auch formen der
partizipation der demokratie die im
internet entstehen möchte die entstehen
social award kann ganz schlechte
auswüchse haben da kann leute richtig
fertiggemacht werden
es kann aber auch unternehmen gezwungen
werden sich anständig zu verhalten es
gibt viele solcher beispiele kit karte
ist zum beispiel ein solches beispiel
lisa schokoriegel
da gab es einmal einen entsprechenden
social mob der innert kürze das
unternehmen gezwungen hat sich
anzupassen an diese frage ist wer bietet
die plattform an natürlich haben wir
über das internet auch enorme vorteile
wir haben alternative medien wir haben
tolle blogs wo teilweise informationen
dann auch verwertet werden die
vielleicht in den offiziellen medien
nicht vorkommen das heißt es gibt viel
weniger medienkontrolle es gibt eine
viel größere offenheit das ist alles gut
aber die frage ist eben wer stellt die
plattform dafür bereit und solange das
private anbieter sind ist eben diese
gefahr dass wir damit eben auch ja
gläsern werden und viel ist auch was als
sharing ökonomie ich meine airbnb das
ist ja zum beispiel ein großes
unternehmen wo man dann so sagt er ist
doch toll da könne man ferienwohnungen
ja wir haben eine große problem in
vielen deutschen städten das tatsächlich
wohnraum entfremdet wird weil es
natürlich lukrativer ist also gerade
berlin oder münchen wo touristen sind
lukrativer dass dort anzubieten als
ferienwohnungen das bedeutet in der
tendenz dass die mieten noch mehr
steigen weil die wohnungsknappheit
akuter wird
also so toll wie das klingt mit sharing
teilen
ich weiß auch nicht ob leute immer alles
teilen wollen natürlich finde ich geb's
ja gebeine alle bereiche wie
mitfahrzentralen und so das ist ja sehen
obwohl sie doch eigentlich gehen wir
doch eigentlich aus im sozialismus aber
jetzt können wir nicht weiter die
frittieren obwohl es noch so viel zu
diskutieren gäbe eine letzte frage frau
wagenknecht ich hab sie gefragt woran
wir erkennen dass die gesellschaft
gerecht ist glauben sie sie erleben die
gerechte gesellschaft noch also wenn ich
mir angucke wie der kapitalismus sich in
den letzten jahren entwickelt hat und
wie stark sich die probleme zuspitzen
dann glaube ich schon und dafür arbeite
ich auch also ich möchte das schon auch
noch erleben
ich danke ihnen sehr verwandt schlecht
haben das gespräch in der sternstunde
kunst geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit
den großen visionen die künstlerin niki
de st fall attestierte sich selbst einen
femininen größen waren und bescherte uns
damit in italien einen fantastischen
skulpturengarten voll praller
lebensfreude die öffnen ihnen jetzt das
gartentor in einem film
große visionen haben auch
internetkonzerne wie google und facebook
und sie alle sind als user teil davon
mein kollege stephan klapproth fragt am
nächsten sonntag die
medienwissenschaftlerin miriam meckel
was das internet mit uns und unserem
leben anstellt danke fürs interesse und
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]